on va en venir alors maintenant à
progresser c'est à vous effectivement on
peut pas y robert contrer et on goûte
reckitt très bien repris et ça si je ne
s'en va pas criaient sauf si nadira
jurieux évidemment il est enlevé au site
et de quelques basses très haute idée de
lui vers la tension réussi cette
opération marquée par un joli jeu de
faire vendre quelque chose
un produit pas publiquement vouloir
comme je lis je lis tu ainsi alain robbe
grillet a réussi la plus surprenante
entreprise marketing littéraire de
l'époque qui l'a imposé sur le marché
français est en partie sur le marché
américain
un produit parfaitement impropre à la
consommation le nouveau roman la
littérature c'est toujours vous robert
campin 6 passes mais la littérature
classique comme celle de procès c'est de
parler de tout le monde la littérature
nouvelle en juillet et c'est de ne
parler de personnes ne soyons pas
passéiste elle est en accord avec les
consignes les aspirations de la nouvelle
société industrielle de type libéral de
type socialiste
si cette société s'installe et suez sur
toute la planète cette littérature sera
celle de l'avenir et alain robbe grillet
non seulement aura sa place à l'académie
française et celle d'e.on c'est
moralement déjà fait mais il aura sa
statue partout de times square à la
place rouge comme héros civilisateur bon
alors bon est-ce que c'est injurieux b2b
alors martin non non c'est excessif non
pour que vous aviez des avions employer
le mot excessif tout à l'heure n'est ce
pas un peu excessif on n'a qu'à pousser
la balle dans l'eau jaoul à cela alors
je vous êtes passé ''sans la mesure où
vous êtes du côté de la civilisation
technique
je veux dire pourquoi je trouve ça
excessif alors en place on injurie
progressif censément c'est une
entreprise de marketing
bon alors ce serait donc un personnage
qui se serait mis d'une part à écrire
volontairement des choses complètement
indigeste et imbuvable et qui
deuxièmement aurait eu pour entreprises
de le promouvoir sur le marché avec des
méthodes parfois sais pas je devrais je
devrais faire une carrière d'un
publicité cela possible
j'ai faite parce que far musulmane c'est
pas ça qui est là parce que par dessus
le marché
en fait d'entreprises de marketing voilà
trente ans que ça dure car voilà trente
ans que ce type d'injures jeu les règles
je le recueil dans la presse ou là vous
l'avez dit dorgelès de l'adie des tous
vos amis l'ont dit et c'est evian
henriot met en rayon avec tout à fait
une autre conscience voulons dire à
moore et autres des mauges ray henriot
avait une espèce de gentillesse pour mon
projet je rencontre une fois henriot
après la jalousie il avait publié un
grand article de ce style sera jalousie
et il me dit vous voyez où était
charmant qui ont été bons il a bien un
sourire j'en tire des grandes moustaches
on avait été à ensemble à azincourt must
est formidable et il me dit vous avez vu
pour prier je vous ai fait un grand tour
au rez-de-chaussée dans le monde j mais
c'est plutôt injurieux parce qu'il
disait que ça relevait des erreurs à
lloris a relevé d asile d asile de fous
de la troisième chambre correctionnelle
c'est un truc comme ça et orion me dit
mais robbe grillet penser un peu si j'en
avais dit du bien de quoi vous auriez
l'air donc il avait cette espèce de
conscience qu effectivement il y avait
deux clans donc notre clip alors jean
gilles c'est un petit roman mais je dois
dire qu'il remplit beaucoup de fils
puisque c'est à la fois un roman
policier c'est aussi un roman
fantastique c'est un petit peu un roman
d'amour et c'est en même temps un livre
pour apprendre le français
fédérer c'est tout ça alors alors
d'abord ce qui est plus surprenant que
c'est qu'un roman servent à apprendre le
français si j'ai bien compris aux états
unis ça c'est fut créé en france aussi
voilà qu'il est séparent seulement aux
états unis voilà maintenant que la
france elle même est en veille dans des
lycées et collèges français l'ont
adoptée pour l'enseignement de la
grammaire raisons à cela une raison à ça
c'est que comme les gens n'y comprennent
rien
les professeurs sont obligés de vous
expliquer ils sont champions parce qu'on
y retrouve une raison celui
dans les jus les verts ont retrouvé une
raison d'être parce qu'il fallait un
mode d'emploi pour lire brûlé et alors
non mais je veux dire celui-là vous
n'allez pas me dire que vous n'avez pas
compris quand même si c'est très clair
ah bon c'est pas tout compris et elle
titrait et vous allez l'apprendre par
coeur pour apprendre la grammaire qui
paraît-il vous fait défaut
oui mais lors de mon histoire alors
devant l'histoire
bon on en vient un petit peu si vous
voulez à ce qui peut opposer en somme
les anciens et les modernes c'est
quelque chose que je peux pas expliquer
très clairement mais que je perçois plus
en plus il ya il ya deux types de
rapports au monde
il ya les écrivains pour lesquels le
monde et rassurant familier c'est le
monde de l'homme si vous voulez c'est à
dire que les valeurs de l'homme peuvent
y opérer la conscience de l'homme il
règne en maîtresse etc
et puis alors il ya dans ma vie
personnelle c'est pas comme ça que je
rencontre le monde le monde est étranger
à chaque instant il a l'air familier
je suis dans une ruelle du côté de la
gare du nord mais je commence à raconter
de livres je reconnais les maisons le et
puis tout d'un coup quelque chose
bascule un enfant jaillit de d'une
maison traverse la rue devant moi buts
sur les pavés disjoints tombe il ya une
flaque rouge c'est pas du sang non je le
prends dans mes bras pour l'amener dans
une maison juste voir dans la porte est
ouverte
il est léger extraordinairement léger
bizarrement léger et puis il est vêtu de
façon pas normal comme si c'était un
enfant du siècle dernier est deja ben
hilli a donc toute une famille
d'écrivains pour qui justement le besoin
d'écrire n'est pas d'expliquer la
familiarité du monde mais au contraire
de tenter d'explorer et de mieux
connaître ça va vous plaire cette part
du monde que justement on ne comprend
pas bien le monde est inquiétant et on
rencontre l'inquiétude à chacun
et c'est la régionalité au fantastique
peut-être que le fantastique a un
rapport avec la modernité n'est pas
forcément tous les autres écrivains
dernier tous les sens du mot t de
l'homme oui tous les écrivains sont du
côté de l'homme et puis albert camus qui
était un humaniste tout d'un coup ce qui
le passionne c'est l'étrangeté du monde
et puis sartre dans la nausée aussi
voilà sartre toute formation
ah oui mais attendez l'homme
complètement étranger au monde qui
n'appartient plus à seulement parce
qu'il lui semble tout d'un coup être ne
pas être chez lui et en même temps être
chez lui là la familiarité et puis il ya
des choses bizarres tout d'un coup le
vert dont parle sartre yahia se verte
il perd son sens inné et comme si toutes
ces fonctions se dégrader comme si son
nom même disparaît c est qu il y avait
là quelque chose d'incompréhensible de
monstrueux qui pourtant est le monde
bon alors ce son si vous voulez ses
rapports au monde qui sont plus ou moins
à l'origine de tous mes livres dont vous
avez parlé pour celui-là de la grande
mère alors je dis en deux mots pour
messieurs les jurés
c'est une vieille idée que j'ai depuis
longtemps que la langue dans laquelle on
écrit donc pour moi la langue française
du 20e siècle que cette langue est
extraordinairement importante c'est à
dire que un écrivain japonais un
écrivain hébreu un écrivain français
n'écrivent pas la même chose dès le
départ parce qu'ils n'écrivent pas dans
la même langue la langue comporte un
certain nombre de comment dire
deux possibilités et ses possibilités
sont créatrices de sens le fait qu'en
france et y ait trois passes et
différents la passe le passé semble pas
se reposer l'imparfait par exemple sacré
quelque chose qui n'existe pas du tout
en anglais respect et qu'ils alors que
le français et l'anglais sont de langue
aussi dans ses réserves
bon et alors j'ai donc depuis très
longtemps j'ai imaginé d'explorer en
somme une espèce de progression
grammaticales qui serait comme l'entrée
dans ce monde
parce qu'en alors vous avez dit
fantastique mais il ya des temps qui
sont fantastiques en français le futur
antérieur futur antérieur avec un temps
de fantastique absolument le
conditionnel
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ce sont des
choses ça existe ça n'existe pas les
choses au conditionnel ça existe
puisqu'on peut les dire
du point de vue de la théorie de
l'existant ça existe dans les dix et
pourtant elles sont conditionnels c'est
à dire que elle n'existe que si que etc
le futur antérieur très bizarre n'est-ce
pas et les emplois du futur intérieur
bon alors avec ses idées que j'avais
depuis une dizaine d'années tout d'un
coup
enseignant à ucla où j'étais professeur
de moi même comme vous signaler avec
ironie dans les universités de
californie à los angeles
bon parce que tout le monde connaît pas
eh ben ils fussent ils ont tous des
défis shirt avec là dessus comme
mondiale comme on dit en france parce
que ça veut dire non je rencontre des
professeurs qui se plaignent des textes
dont ils se servent pour apprendre le
français aux étudiants de seconde année
ce sont soit des textes écrits par des
professeurs de deux langues et qui
disent ses professeurs eux-mêmes sont
évidemment assez naïf et fous rires les
étudiants il faudrait qu'un écrivain
accepte d'écrire les textes en question
un écrivain qui écrit bien comme dit
qu'en terre ou bien alors prendre
l'étranger qui a beaucoup servi à ça
mais alors les gosses n'apprennent que
le passé composé
et quand plus tard il tombe sur la libre
de balzac ou de flaubert et 10% qu'est
ce que ça veut dire on n'y comprend rien
du tout et c'est donc il y avait et je
me suis dit hé bien je vais faire ça
parce que le les professeurs en question
disait c'est pas acceptable par un
écrivain de des contraintes du rachis
moi je connais des écrivains comme
valéry ou mallarmé ça ça les aurait
musée eh bien ça m'a amusé je me suis
beaucoup amusé ça et c'est ça c'est la
grande mère qui a engendré l'histoire et
si c'est devenu un roman de science
fiction que comme vous l'avez dit je
dirais fantastique pas d'un roman de
l'anthracite y campe un roman policier
en augmentation à stx et c'est à dire
des mondes qui communique tout d'un coup
par des pavés ça il ya des ya des vannes
ya des sas des mondiaux personnage est
entraîné dans des dents des
jean des leurs dans des chausse-trappes
à son insu maintenant nous avons alors
dans des dédoublements aussi bien
entendu est-ce qu'on n'ait pas été
sensible moi j'ai été sensible à
l'humour droguerie en tout cas dans ce
livre je suis toujours sensible à
l'humour de robbe grillet dans la
conversation dans la discussion ou dans
la vie qu'un départ n'est pas dans ce
livre dit souvent des choses énormes
avec un sérieux il vient encore d'en
donner une démonstration son épouse me
semble évident dans ce livre là j'en
suis moins sûr mais je ne suis pas du
tout sûr que ce soit aussi clair que
vous dites c'est à dire qu'elle a une
aventure qui est prise dans le livre de
science fiction mais on a l'impression à
chaque chapitre que robbe grillet bas
les cartes et les redistribue d'une
façon différente quand vous vivez quand
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
tout est si clair ou que justement on
est sans cesse en train d'avoir des
cartes entre les mains et de se demander
comment les arranger pour vivre que vous
battez liberté que vous faites c'est ce
que c'est que la liberté même l'ampleur
et les avions si ce n'est justement
aller loin dans l'ordre les cartes qu'on
m'a donné j'ai tout à fond me donne les
cartes pour jouer pour jouer madame fait
jour j tout le monde des étuis
l'arrangement de ses cartes dans ma main
mais bien être mon intervention sur le
monde mal berne est libre de jouer aux
cartes mai 2000 mais c'est à peu près ce
que vous faites moi les remarques à le
jouer aux cartes et jeux et jouets
martial il faut travailler sur le lido
robbe grillet et bien je trouvais assez
intéressant il haïra 6ème assez curieux
parce que dans un sens il va traiter il
se rapprochait de moi parce que son
roman recommence n'est ce pas il ya ces
miroirs et l'histoire est reprise
plusieurs fois et corrigé elle prend un
autre sens et ça je trouvais ça très
intéressant je vais vraiment lire michel
d alors alain bertrand poirot-delpech
moi je suis je trouvais ce livre
passionnant j'aime beaucoup l'humour de
leur grille et j'adhère tout ce qu'il
dit sur la façon dont la firme en jouer
avec la langue c'est ce et c'est
l'essentiel
mais je pense qu'il n'a pas le monopole
du sentiment d'étrangeté de l'expression
d'étranges prépare également le projet
ce type tout un tas de petits camarades
qui faisait pareil
et ô miracle et les mauvais qui sont
beaucoup plus lisible entre guillemets
pense que modiano elle une page de
modiano on est dans l'étrangeté absolue
et il ne va pas les cartes c'est une
histoire limpide et qui se lit sans
problème alors que parfois vous poser
des problèmes mais c'est c'est ça c'est
ça le livre t ou le livre au sterenn
aussi c'est le grand jeu tout le monde
va l'être le monde aller dans des
gobelets marque de l'étrangeté du monde
le monde me pose des problèmes pourquoi
j'écris c'est parce que justement voir
comment ces problèmes sont aussi des
problèmes des problèmes d'écriture des
problèmes de langue vous de poser des
problèmes aux bons c'est ce que vous
n'arrangeait pas les choses dans vos
romans de telle manière qu'elles
souhaitent difficilement pas trop
difficile à prendre dit fier on a dit ça
de toute l'époque moderne on a dit ça de
tous les grands philosophes du 20e
siècle et c'est l'outsider fed arrange
aussi ne pense pas que vous soyez un
quelqu'un de l'importance si je ne dois
pas vous blesser si ce n'est pas
injurieux de l'importance de vous seul
ou de rats étaient bien vous ne vous
étonnez d'ailleurs pas être philosophe
mais ce qui me semble très souvent à la
lecture des livres de robbe grillet
c'est que j'ai à faire à ses dessins et
comme on en voyait dans le temps où on
voyait un chasseur qui marche et on
disait chercher sont jetés et pour
tourner le décès et voici l'allemand et
non les relations mais ces dames avis
que ça se passe voilà où est du chien
non ça ne se passe pas dans la vie dans
la vie le chasseur associés et une en or
on n'est pas obligé de retourner l'arbre
cul par dessus tête pour voir le chien
noyé dans ses regrets sont réalité nous
ne fréquentons pas le même sens de l'art
de bonnes non seulement à traction mais
ce n'est pas aux dires des anciens et
des modernes c'est que le monde n'est
pas le même mais je ne pense pas que les
modernes soient tous du côté de ses jeux
d'esprit je pense que notre 25 ou 30 ans
que le nouveau roman ixus sa fécondité
mais pas encore éclater or il y avait
aussi écrit qu'en terre c'est un peu
plus loin que malheureusement le nouveau
roman où mes oeuvres en particulier
n'ont pas atteint le public que tous les
oeuvres ordinaire alors ça je proteste
beaucoup ils n'ont pas atteint tout de
suite mais un livre comme la jalousie
comme vous avez n'a pas une critique
favorable à l'époque qui a été rejetée
par l'ensemble de la presse
évidemment la vendue très peu les
premières années évidemment évidemment
mais à l'heure actuelle il atteint 150
milles et il ya des tas de livres qui
ont été grands succès à l'époque
donnant du sens millet dont on l'a
oublié complètement longueur le livre et
cetera vous parler de nous parler
marketing
non seulement il existe encore au bout
de 30 ans mais par dessus le marché il
existe mieux en mieux et qui me semble
être allé le moins bien dans le sens de
la fécondité du nouveau roman c'est que
les autres romanciers la littérature
vivante d'aujourd'hui n'est peut être
pas du côté de l'hôtellerie et de votre
école fois vous avez lu le dernier
casino que ce dont vous avez pleuré
parce qu'il est parlé même s'il est venu
apostrophe way et ce n'est peut-être pas
un dc bord d'europe criais mais je veux
dire que donnent les auteurs vivants les
autos comédienne aude au chaos delpech
parler nous attendons évidemment comme
peuple comme le précise par exemple que
tous les auteurs vivants d'aujourd'hui
sont presque tous étrangers au courant
du nouveau roman mort deux gardiens
evans en ce cas là je